[Music]
what's your name
a year are you
you know who I am my name is Stephen
Hawking the monopoly so you know I'm
looking for players asked me if I could
sell tickets
you wrote this annotation I did yet and
you're directing and starring in
ambitious before I use your wrong to
finally do some work that she means
something I worry about the numbers
don't worry about what the other guys
are thinking you're here for a reason I
want to be great I just want to get the
bad guy would you like to play there are
no two words in the English language
harmful than good job all these guys and
know your name make feel invincible you
up there
not quite booked in here this is my beer
respected and validated remember that
you told me that's how you got me into
this [ __ ]
you know the director get them under
control okay do you wanna die you know
what I realized in my life is just gonna
go like that a series of milestones
getting married having kids getting
divorced
you know what's next huh my beautiful is
this for real or are you shooting a film
assume you know people are foolish